que no es tan difícil de convencer a alguien
para que traicione a otros.
Incluso algunos de los disidentes más famosos de la Alemania Oriental
colaboraron con la Stasi,
por ejemplo Ibrahim Böhme.
En 1989 era el líder de la revolución pacífica
y casi es el primer Primer Ministro elegido democráticamente de la RDA
sino es porque se descubre que había sido un informante.
La red de espías era muy vasta.
En casi todas las instituciones,
hasta en las iglesias, o en la Alemania Occidental,
había muchos de ellos.
Recuerdo que le dije a un importante oficial de la Stasi:
"Si me hubiera mandado un informante,
de seguro lo habría reconocido".
Su respuesta fue:
"No le mandamos a nadie.
Usamos a los que estaban a su alrededor".
De hecho, dos de mis mejores amigos
me reportaban a la Stasi.
No solo en mi caso los informantes era muy allegados.
Por ejemplo, para Vera Lengsfeld, otra disidente famosa,
su esposo era el que la espiaba.
Un escritor famoso fue traicionado por su hermano.
Esto me recuerda la novela "1984" de George Orwell,
en la que la única persona aparentemente confiable
era un informante.
Pero ¿por qué la Stasi recolectaba toda esta información
en sus archivos?
Su propósito principal era controlar la sociedad.
En casi todos sus discursos, el ministro de la Stasi
daba órdenes de averiguar quién era quién,
o quién pensaba qué.
No quería esperar hasta que alguien
intentara actuar contra el régimen.
Quería saber por adelantado
lo que la gente pensaba y planeaba.
Los alemanes del este sabían
que estaban rodeados de informantes,
en un régimen totalitario que creaba desconfianza
y en un estado de terror colectivo,
la herramienta más importante para oprimir a la gente
en cualquier dictadura.
Por eso no muchos alemanes del este trataron
de luchar contra el régimen comunista.
Si así fuera, la Stasi usaba un método
que era realmente diabólico.
Se llamaba Zersetzung,
y está descrito en otro lineamiento.
La palabra es difícil de traducir porque originalmente
significa "biodegradación".
Pero es una descripción muy precisa.
La meta era destruir secretamente
la autoestima de la gente,
al dañar su reputación,
crear fallas en su trabajo,
y destruir sus relaciones personales.
Consideren esto, Alemania Oriental, era una dictadura moderna.
La Stasi no trató de arrestar a todos los disidentes.
Prefería neutralizarlos,
y podía hacerlo porque
tenía mucho acceso a información personal
y a muchas instituciones.
Detener a alguien solo se hacía
en última instancia.
Para ello, la Stasi tenía 17 prisiones preventivas,
una en cada distrito.
La Stasi había creado
unos métodos de detención muy modernos.
Normalmente el oficial que interrogaba
no torturaba al prisionero.
En su lugar se usaba un sofisticado sistema
de presión psicológica,
donde lo principal era el aislamiento.
Casi ningún prisionero se resistía
a no dar testimonio.
Si tienen la oportunidad,
visiten una prisión de la antigua Stasi en Berlín
y tomen un tour guiado por un antiguo prisionero político
que les explicará cómo funcionaba eso.
Hay que responder a otra pregunta:
Si la Stasi estaba tan bien organizada,
¿por qué colapsó el régimen comunista?
Primero, en 1989, los líderes de la Alemania Oriental
no sabían qué hacer contra
las crecientes protestas de la gente.
Era especialmente confuso
porque en la "patria madre" del socialismo,
la Unión Soviética,
se habían instaurado políticas más liberales.
Además, el régimen dependía
de los préstamos del Occidente.
Por eso no se le dio ninguna orden a la Stasi
para aplacar estos levantamientos.
Segundo, en la ideología comunista
no hay lugar para la crítica.
Más bien los líderes estaban convencidos
de que el socialismo era un sistema perfecto
y que la Stasi tenía que confirmarlo.
La consecuencia fue
que a pesar de toda la información,
el régimen no podía analizar sus problemas verdaderos
y por ende, no podía resolverlos.
Al final la Stasi dejó de existir
gracias a las estructuras
que estaba encargada de proteger.
El final de la Stasi
fue algo trágico
porque los oficiales
se mantuvieron ocupados durante la revolución pacífica
con una sola tarea:
destruir los documentos
que habían producido por décadas.
Afortunadamente,
activistas de derechos humanos los detuvieron.
Por eso hoy en día podemos usar esos archivos
para lograr un mejor entendimiento
de cómo funciona el estado de vigilancia.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Bruno Giussani: Gracias. Muchas gracias.
Hubertus, quiero hacerte un par de preguntas
porque aquí tengo el Der Spiegel de la semana pasada.
"Mein Nachbar NSA". Mi vecino, la NSA (Agencia de Supervisión Nacional)
Y tú nos acabas de hablar acerca de mi vecino,
los espías e informantes de la Alemania Oriental.
¿Hay alguna relación directa
entre estas dos historias o no?
¿Cuál fue tu reacción como historiador al ver esto?
HK: Creo que hay que mencionar
varios aspectos.
Primero, creo que hay una diferencia
en la razón por la que Uds. recogen estos datos.
¿Lo hacen para proteger a su gente
contra los ataques terroristas,
o lo hacen para oprimir a su gente?
Allí está la diferencia fundamental.
Pero por otra parte,
incluso en una democracia se puede abusar de estas herramientas,
y esto es algo por lo que tenemos
que estar alerta para pararlo,
y para que los servicios de inteligencia
respeten las reglas que existen.
El tercer punto, probablemente,
es que realmente tenemos que apreciar que vivimos en democracia
porque puedes estar seguro de que en Rusia y en China
se está haciendo lo mismo,
pero nadie habla de eso
porque nadie puede.
(Aplausos)
BG: Cuando la historia apareció por primera vez
en julio del año pasado,
presentaste una demanda criminal
ante un tribunal alemán. ¿Por qué?
HK: Sí, lo hice por el segundo punto que mencioné,
que creo que, especialmente en una democracia,
las reglas son para todos.
Están creadas para todos, así que no está permitido
que ninguna institución no respecte las reglas.
En el código criminal alemán está establecido
que no se puede espiar a nadie
sin el permiso de un juez.
Afortunadamente, está establecido en el código criminal alemán
así que si no se respecta,
creo que es necesaria una investigación.
Y tomó mucho tiempo
antes de que un fiscal público alemán lo hiciera,
y comenzó solo en el caso de Angela Merkel,
y no en el caso de todos los habitantes en Alemania.
BG: Eso no me sorprende porque
—(Aplausos) —
por la historia que contaste.
Visto desde afuera, vivo fuera de Alemania,
esperaba que Alemania reaccionara
más fuertemente, inmediatamente.
Sin embargo, la reacción vino solo
cuando la Canciller Merkel reveló
que la estaban espiando. ¿Por qué?
HK: Lo tomo como una buena señal
porque la gente se siente segura en esta democracia.
No temen ser arrestados,
y si sales de este auditorio luego de la conferencia,
nadie teme que la policía secreta
esté afuera y que te vaya a arrestar.
Creo que esa es una buena señal.
La gente no está realmente atemorizada como pudieran estarlo.
Pero por supuesto que creo que las instituciones
son responsable de detener las acciones ilegales
en Alemania o donde sea que ocurran.
BG: Una pregunta personal, y esta es la última.
Ha habido un debate en Alemania acerca
de darle asilo a Edward Snowden.
¿Estás a favor o en contra?
HK: Oh, esa es una pregunta difícil,
pero si me preguntas
y te respondo honestamente,
le daría asilo
porque creo que lo que hizo fue muy valiente,
y que destruyó toda su vida,
su familia, todo.
Creo que debemos hacer algo por estos individuos.
Especialmente si ves la historia alemana,
donde tanta gente tuvo que escapar,
y pidió asilo en otros países
y no lo obtuvieron,
creo que sería una buena señal darle asilo.
(Aplausos)
BG: Hubertus, muchas gracias.